hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to the try not to laugh
challenge now I know it's been a while
since the last one and I meant to get to
it sooner but that dang ol punishment
hasn't come yet and I was gonna do that
before I got to the next one but we got
some sidetracked by other projects I
thought that I just try not to laugh
again before I get my ass handed to me
by my so-called friends but first we got
more Internet videos to with to laugh at
or maybe not laugh hopefully not laugh
and I'm not gonna make any promises
about this one but I'm gonna try my
damnedest to think of death
Oh
[Music]
it was like it was like a compilation of
all the other funny videos that I've
seen over the years [ __ ] dude alright
okay well starting off strong this time
but I didn't live not funny
not not funny I'm not laughing you
haven't no murmur murmur murmur for me
so you're the one who stains the whoever
found it well that you'd like me to be
you wouldn't be but it's too late
you snows you lows you sleep you wait
you Napa you get slapped for you slumber
a cucumber you catch up on some Zed's
you get out of my head you slumber you
are about as deep as a bowl of soup and
your tongue is about as sharp as a 6-pin
say what you want about me but lay off
the soup you only got one peel I let me
see a see with your eyes not with your
mouth I'll call your bluff I'll see your
penis with your mouth and I raise you
with my head auntie oh oh what's wrong I
crapped out but I'm tough I can suck it
up okay count of three we show what's
under the loincloth Wiener take me off
take one
[Music]
goddamn I wanted to okay all right well
okay take cocaine all the time you
should be nose deep in that stuff
non-stop right but you're not why what's
wrong with you people
you're ready man dominance art there's
hundreds of the bloody things then you
might ask yourself that's the question I
don't think any sane person cannot be
crazy you know I mean everybody's flawed
loses that doesn't mean they're right
that's not exactly the point good luck
with all right then dude she's singing
our song bro what's her name
[Music]
nope not funny not funny I will not be
broken into laughter by a pooping but
greatest nation as some say one that to
this day still grows and matures this
our home this our country that we love
which we all celebrate July the former
justice the man who made us completely
free of British tyranny which reigned
South and North free from this we joined
together in bliss to honor all fine
don't do it no no no no don't do it no
no no no I'm afraid you
nope oh I'm sorry okay well I broke I'll
go a few more I broke break you know
I'll go always do a few more so as you
go I'm in the giggly mood it's free real
estate not funny even in a giggly mode
[Music]
[Laughter]
funny funny funny bunny this is the knit
wild Nick and it's a natural habitat
Alex Alex you just dropped it in the
book
[Music]
[Laughter]
and that's good okay so I didn't win
obviously but then I wasn't gonna so
what can i really say about being the
person that I am I'm a giggly [ __ ] so
we all knew that but thank you again
everybody for joining me on another
adventure into trying not to laugh it
failed and I am a loser and I will take
that punishment that is coming for me
sometime soon don't know when but it'll
happen so thank you everybody so much
for watching let me know what you
thought of these down in the comments
below if you want to see more funny
stuff in the future let me know as well
thanks again and as always I will see
you in the next video bye bye